pretty clear from that statement that
russia's dismayed by the lack of
diplomacy but also the lack of humanity
that the eu chief has recently shown
again politics
beats cooperation when it comes to the
covert 19 vaccine
for the eu it really has been a struggle
a struggle to get production off the
ground a struggle to get jabs in arms
a struggle with the uk over who gets
however many doses
and the slowness in inoculating its 450
million strong
population has got people angry and
frustrated this was
in their view a political test brussels
failed
to the point that uh vandalian had to
publicly
uh apologize the fact is that today
we're
not where we want to be in combating the
virus we were late in granting
authorization
we were too optimistic about mass
production and maybe we also took for
granted that the doses audit would
actually arrive on time we must ask
ourselves why
and what lessons we can draw from it
well one lesson that did come out of it
was that the eu's been so
inefficient that individual member
states have been forced to go out on
their own
looking for alternatives and they're
looking at russia
hungary for example has registered for
emergency use sputnik v
we also heard austria and the czech
republic showing an appetite for the
russian vaccine
so here we've got ursula van der laan uh
buried by criticism
uh humiliated by having to say sorry
feeling the pressure
what better way to divert attention from
all the problems in your backyard
than by flinging accusations at another
country in fact let's remind ourselves
of exactly what it was that she said
overall i must say um
we still wonder uh why russia
is offering um theoretically millions
and millions of doses
while not sufficiently progressing in
vaccinating
the own people this is also a question i
think that should be answered
but do van der lion's concerns have any
ground here i mean i understand that
sputnik v
is being registered in 29 countries
already but what's the situation right
here within russia
well from the very get-go as soon as
russia became the first country
in the world to register a covert 19
vaccine
president putin said russians come first
they are our priority
and this was something that was
reiterated by the officials in brussels
representatives of the russian
authorities scientific community and
business entities
have repeatedly publicly stressed that
vaccination of its own citizens
constitutes an absolute priority for
russia in its fight against kovate 19
in full compliance with the principles
of democracy and humanitarian law
inoculation in russia is voluntary and
to date all interested citizens
are provided with the vaccine without
delay and free of charge
well that free accessibility is
undeniably a seen success
russia is in top three of european
nations in terms of vaccinations at last
count
2.2 million including many of our
colleagues who described how smooth the
process was
you know they turned up they didn't have
to book in advance they did their
medical check they got first dozen the
second dose then they went home and they
were getting back to normal life
at the same time we're seeing a very
positive dynamic in terms of case
numbers which are steadily declining
uh day on day that said as in every
single country not everyone is
racing to go and get that jab at least
not quite yet
and this discrepancy between internal
and external demand
is something that moscow raised recently
we haven't had any reports about vaccine
shortages anywhere
domestic demand for this vaccine is
still gathering momentum
in moscow there's no deficit but we
can't say there's a huge demand
as for demand for the russian vaccine
abroad it is indeed high
it's so high that it surpasses our
production capacity
that's why we are actively working on
quickly launching production of the
russian vaccine in several foreign
countries
production in foreign countries will
cover demand abroad while manufacturing
inside the country will cover the
domestic market
so clearly that's the logical response
to vondalen's
quite hostile comments but here clearly
throwing that political punch was more
important than logic
perhaps not surprising we obviously know
the eu russian relations are going
through a slightly bumpy
patch moscow says it's frustrated by
brussels consistently interfering in its
internal affairs
and it looks like here we might be
seeing the same story instead of trying
to resolve its own issues
the eu is trying to deflect attention
and undermining a country who's trying
to offer
a helping hand